we want to know where this virus came  from we want to understand it not just  because it helps us  manage this one but prevent future ones  but the other part  is we have got to stop politicizing this  like my god at this point we have  managed to take this thing that's a very  complicated and important scientific  question and people are talking about it  as though like if you're a democrat you  believe one thing in a republican you  believe another  i just don't know the right answer we  need to investigate it we need to push  china to give us  more cooperation we need to have the u.s  intelligence and other intelligence  agencies investigated  we really do need to get to the bottom  bottom of this again if i were a betting  person i'd say probably came from an  animal but we're not we're not making  bets here we should actually sort it out